so i see this video on tick tock
four psychological ways to make someone
like you
and tyler i'm gonna have to do some live
reacts to this one so you're gonna be
prepared to pause because it's just too
much going on
all right i by the way respect these
people who post these videos because you
know it provides me with commentary all
right so let's start let's see
what she has to say what's her name
kimberly ask kimberly ask kimberly
somebody asked she answered let's see
what she had to say
want someone to like you more there are
some really specific psychological
things you can do that can actually make
a world of difference as a relationship
therapist i've literally spoken to
somebody tell me why she's doing this
while she's putting makeup on
listen i'm all for you putting makeup on
if it's a makeup tutorial but why do you
need your relationship excerpt why do i
need to watch you like oil of old lay
your skin while you're telling me what i
mean not just right off the bat i'm lost
i'm confused i'm distracted and she like
she just put it on and didn't rub it in
so she had uneven patches all over her
face can you imagine me doing this show
i walk in and we're going to talk about
the d.a of new york you're just sitting
there putting blush on some lotion
by the way this lotion has a little
sparkle for those at home that's for you
today just saying but imagine me putting
on you know
what what is even going on i'm already
like what i'm already frazzled tick-tock
makes people weird tick-tock she felt
like she had to be doing something i was
like is this like the actor's studio
where they say you gotta be doing you
know my mom used to tell me you gotta be
doing in action or you lose the moment
i'm like is that what what is going on
here mom help me out if you're listening
okay
so that all right let's see let's see
let's give her the benefit of the doubt
i'll try not to be here we go i'm in
psychology so i know that these things
we need sound the first thing you're
going to do is take advantage of the
reciprocal liking concept when you see
them in person you are going to act so
genuinely excited oh my god i'm so
excited to see you in ketchup okay
listen don't do this i'm already i can't
i really tried first of all before we
okay don't try to make people like you
i don't know why she's supposed to be
some type of relationship expert you
don't she's talking about relationships
people you want to get with that's what
she's going after stop trying to make
somebody like if you have to try to make
them like you
you're already on the wrong foot
forget it
because you're already trying too hard
you know how that reads desperate
it reads desperate women won't like it
men won't like it it reads desperate if
somebody she's telling you oh come up to
and say oh we have something in common
if you did that to me if i were in the
dating phase which i'm not and you did
that to me i'd be like ugh this guy's
trying who's trying to say he knows my
sister or something like how do i get
out of this how do i disentangle myself
from the situation spider-man swing down
from a building and grab me
okay let's keep going
we talked about last time you're
probably thinking that kimberly like
shouldn't i be playing it cool like
shouldn't i be waiting for them to come
and talk to me and the answer is
absolutely not we're gonna treat them
like you have a very special connection
and this is because our brains are
psychologically primed to like people
more when we know that they like us and
think we're a good person this isn't
even a flirty thing at all this is
literally that they feel safe and seen
with you and they know that you see the
absolute best in them next thing you're
going to do in your conversation you are
going to point out something that is
similar about both of you oh my gosh i
can't believe we both have a sister i
mean can you could you imagine someone
coming up to you tyler can't even keep
it together we both wear shoes right oh
my god you like white t-shirts too
i also have a sister i mean you would
live this is a person you would be like
you would you would try to get out of
that situation and then you would go
home and you'd call your friend and
you'd be like i met this crazy guy you
wouldn't believe the [ __ ] this desperate
guy was doing i think you'd just laugh
in their face you laugh like how do you
hold it together like
right you'd be like do i know you also
in this day and age you might if you're
a woman be like ooh he's a little creepy
what do you mean you know you also have
a sister how do you know i have a did
you stalk me online this is all wrong
also the makeup's going wrong all i can
think of is the lion king the lion king
where they put the makeup on yes that's
how you contour face i don't contour my
face people at home may notice i don't
wear a lot of makeup i'm not into this
whole scene by the end of the video by
the way the lashes are like it's like
it's a transformation is all i'm gonna
say i don't know maybe this was a video
about makeup and she's actually trying
to get a job as a makeup artist and
we're the fools i don't know how to make
people just apply a lot of makeup a lot
of makeup this was like watch wait to
see the end of the video look at just
trust me and look at the eyelashes at
the end not trying to make fun but
something i don't know okay let's let's
keep going because the end part is the
best part okay
wow the human brain does unconsciously
choose people who we view as similar to
us next thing when people especially men
see bare skin
they get aroused i hate to admit it but
the sundress phenomenon is a real thing
there is a reason why guys like these so
much your comfort is key when it comes
to dressing in front of anybody but if
you want to play it psychologically it
will not hurt you to show a little bit
of their skin finally this is the kicker
if you are not in a relationship you're
going to make sure that you give other
guys the time of day this brings out a
protective instinct okay so let's pause
it here just to take a moment to observe
the eyelashes i'm not sure what's going
on there there's fake eyelashes
obviously but i don't know how many sets
four five six something happened in in
she paused that video went and did
something applied something and came
back different is all i'm gonna say all
right
first of all don't don't chill ladies
she's got to be in the millennial age
bracket i just know it don't show bare
skin to make man happy okay some of the
sexiest
sexiest women i know
button up to here
they're gorgeous they're stunning they
leave you wondering what's going on
right don't show if you want to show
skin for yourself if you're feeling like
you want a little sparkle going on that
day you do it don't do that to get a man
it's insulting you are already again
starting on the wrong foot of how to
please how to make them like me don't be
that person and finally i love the last
bit of advice about oh you got to make
them jealous
don't play games with men
don't play games with men they know it
and maybe that guy in that moment you're
right sometimes men can be like a little
puppy you pull them along maybe that guy
will get jealous in that moment do you
know how long you will hold his interest
if you play a game like that five
minutes that is very temporary and there
that is very fleeting
if a guy really likes you you don't have
to do any of this
any of it
you can be extremely subtle you are just
yourself they will be intrigued enough
by you
none of this and this stuff will turn a
lot of men off too because they'll see
it as desperate they'll see it as a girl
who's aiming to oh she's the god she
must really like me so much my gosh i
mean i don't even know her that was
talking about my sister how does she
know my what is going on here
okay also just a bit of advice don't
wear that much makeup on the date i'm
just saying guys no tyler
did you not notice was that did not did
that not feel like a bit much that's a
that's a transformation if i've ever
seen one todd's trying to be nice
trying to call it a transformation but
so
wyatt made a really good point in here
uh what's the what's the over under that
she's actually single
she you know well often she's given this
advice at the time these people it's
like dating expert and they're like oh
are you married no
she she probably went on like six days
maybe she did that
maybe she did that and they all just ran
away screaming first of all maybe she
put all that makeup on guys typically by
the way ladies
okay let's talk about makeup for a
second
guys don't like all that going on you
know why because guys like to go to bed
on a monday night with someone who looks
like themselves and that person is who
they wake up to the next morning it's
the same face
what they don't like is they go out to
the club on a monday night and they see
you and you're all lit up
you're a kardashian-esque
and then you come home take your makeup
off take a shower fall asleep wake up
the next morning and you look like
something else they're like i feel
tricked they don't like all that stuff
women like all that stuff women like the
fake eyelashes and women like the hair
extensions and women like guys really
like natural
this is not going to be a popular
statement and i know there's some guys
that may be out there saying well no i
like their extensions here generally
speaking guys like a woman who's
comfortable in her own
skin if you like the short clip you can
catch another one here or you can catch
the full episode right here